маразм і злочинна діяльність всередині
влади коли аудиторська служба судиться з
державними підприємствами які виробляють
озброєння для української держави для
збройних сил України по що сьогодні
відбувається ви Уявіть собі підприємство
українське підприємство
військово-промислового комплексу яке
займається виробництвом українських
ракет нептунів змушене було цього тижня
розпустити робітників бо вони не можуть
в таких умовах працювати Це
Диверсанти від Влади не треба московитів
коли є От такі владні чиновники які
насправді змушують зупинитися
підприємством нашого українського
військово-промислового комплексу але ми
своєю постановою дали підстави для того
щоб ви судах оцей абсолютно дебільний
збір між аудиторською службою і
державними підприємствами був зупинений